ukrainian president zielinski begging
the west for help as vladimir putin
wages a brutal war
do prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
do prove that you indeed are europeans
and then
life will
win over death and light will win over
darkness yeah we carried that live it
kind of snuck up on us is extremely
emotional speech he got a standing
ovation at the end and in the end the eu
voted 667 voted for their admit of the
of the 676 voters 637 voted to put them
in the european union and zolinski
actually went on today urging president
biden to send a strong useful message to
russia tonight at the state of the union
they talked for 30 minutes the focus of
president biden's big speech now
shifting as fighting in ukraine gets
more horrific biden will also lay out
plans for the economy and covet i
understand that in some ways i think
they're going to talk about how he
brought the world together jesse and it
was uh his idea to call the eu and
reconvene nato and say sanctions gonna
be necessary but we'll wait to see what
happens
before i actually do anything
well you're right the europeans did take
the lead on the sanctions package
but there will be patriotism in the room
tonight you'll have people on both sides
of the aisle rallying to defend ukraine
rallying against mother russia and that
should happen and and that's a good
thing but
with that said this happened on biden's
watch and the threat of sanctions did
not deter vladimir putin and now the
american people are being hurt by this
war the dow has lost about 3 000 points
since the beginning of the year it's
almost off 10
and gas prices are headed to four
dollars a gallon and
he can't come out and brag about the
economy he can't come out and say
everything is great because people are
going to look at the guy and they're
going to think like what country are you
talking about all of the wage gains got
devoured by inflation people are worse
off now than they were before he came in
and he talks about job gains these are
jobs that weren't created these are just
added back after they got lost during
covet so that's not going to fly
speaking of covet he cannot come out and
say he crushed covet
everybody got coveted
heard immunity crushed
i mean yeah he rolled out a bunch of
shots okay that was already teed up for
him so he better not try that there is
so much lingering resentment by parents
for the fact that this guy and his
people masked kids way beyond what was
necessary and the vax mandates hurt
workers got him fired totally
unnecessary so that's what he has to say
he's going to ignore crime he's going to
tap dance around that ignore the border
and i'm not i don't have high
expectations for tonight 140 million
people got cove at harold uh to you so
that's jesse is uh would say it's a big
task for if jesse had to write the
speech for the present united states
what would you emphasize while not
leaving reality tonight
well i think the president has to be has
to be frank with the country our the
state of our union is is
is better than it was a year ago but it
remains unsettled
and inflation and crime
uh covet the border
all of those issues loom large and are
incredibly important in everyday texture
and everyday conversations in our
country
but we would be kidding ourselves if we
didn't recognize what we've been talking
about on this show and your show brian
and across the network for many many
days now
the war in ukraine uh we've all been
dragged into it as president zalinski
has said and it's caused us all to
question how we choose to defend freedom
how we choose to defend independence now
the president shouldn't dwell on this
and shouldn't make this the entire
speech but he certainly should
should talk about this issue in a way
that demonstrates to americans that when
we unite when we rally around a cause as
americans despite our differences
despite the things we may have massive
disagreements about we agree on freedom
and independence of democracy and it's
under attack now it is even under attack
in our own in our own homeland as we
think about how we're going to address
certain issues if i were the president
i'd call on democrats and republicans to
push a reset together and all the things
we've seen over the last week should
make us all as americans want to do do
what's right for every middle class
american every parent every neighborhood
every community i don't care what the
color what the what the racial
background the economic background might
be i hope the president asked democrats
and republicans alike to push the reset
and let's do our very best to advance a
foreign policy that that protects us and
advance an economic plan in the country
that enables and empowers every single
american that's what i'd do if i were
him could this be a unifying moment how
well said uh judge
not a chance not a chance this is a
president who came in and said he was
going to unify he hasn't done anything
to unify and you know what harold with
all due respect i have to disagree with
you i mean we are so much worse off than
we were a year ago a year ago we were a
net exporter of energy a year ago gas
prices weren't what they are now a year
ago inflation wasn't what it is now a
year ago we didn't have the crime
problem that we have now in the in the
in the uh immigration problem let me
tell you what the guy ought to do what
he's going to do before he what he ought
to do what he's going to do is he's not
going to talk about bill back better
because he knows that's got a negative
connotation he'll mention he's not going
to mention he's not going to mention
inflation because he knows that people
understand what that means and it was
transitory anyway and so maybe he
doesn't understand it himself but the
the problem is what i want to know from
him is why in the why is the energy
sector exempt from the sanctions why is
why are we essentially funding the
russian war on ukraine stop with this
nonsense of oh this is an attack against
democracy i'm tired of words i'm tired
of words that are meaningless attack
against democracies under attack i'm
tired of hearing it we are funding the
war in russia and today or yesterday jen
sachi and today senator warner a
democrat both said well we can't turn on
the keystone pipeline it'll take years
before we see the benefits of that
hogwash last year we saw the benefits of
being independent and with our own
energy so stop stop with the nonsense
and give us a straight talk and he won't
do it right uh so uh judge has a
different take i'm gonna watch the show
back and get uh clear how they're
disseminated and i thought i've broken
this up there for now so dana you have
the job to put this speech together but
joe manchin kind of gave you a clue and
so maybe howard harold ford did too
he kept joe manchin came out and said
let's stop buying russian uh oil and gas
and let's start producing our own and i
believe he's still a democrat
i think well he is and i think that's
also one of the reasons you probably
won't hear a lot if he does say build
back better i'd be surprised but i think
we have we haven't mentioned one thing
which is that polls from abc news and
cbs news this week have shown the
president at about a 37 38 approval
rating that is a really negative
territory for a president to go in to a
state of the union in which that speech
is supposed to talk about all of your
accomplishments and
he's going to be looking for a big
applause line and standing ovations but
you know where he's going to get them is
at the front end of the speech when he
talks about ukraine he has a lot of
things he's going to want to get to
katanji brown jackson is a supreme court
nominee she will be there and it will be
a big moment that's a historical
nomination and she will have her chance
to get applause and the support from the
democrats as she begins to get the
have her hearings and hopefully from her
point of view she'll try to win some of
the republicans over as well
he's going to try to talk about a lot of
things in here nobody wants to hear
about climate change and the green new
deal but believe me they're going to
talk about it and that was it's going to
be hard to hold people's attention i
believe because the speech
it takes months to put together and then
you have something like ukraine upend
all of it and everyone across the
government is trying to get their pet
project mentioned in fact i noticed that
the department of interior the secretary
there deb holland she put out a long
statement yesterday about how important
it is that we deal with climate change
okay fine i agree it's not an
unimportant issue but you have to have
some sort of an offering for people you
cannot imagine how
focused the american people are now on
energy policy and what that's doing to
inflation the other thing is he's going
to want to talk about the american
rescue plan
he sees that as a great accomplishment
but what americans have done in the
majority of them has connected the extra
money going into the system that helped
raise prices on everything else so a lot
of the things that he would want to talk
about as
accomplishments are vulnerabilities
except perhaps the infrastructure bill
right and don't forget you have a
rebuttal and then you have a rebuttal to
the rebuttal rashidu talib is going to
come out and he's going to call out our
president i've never seen anything like
it the this guy congressman gottlieb
said it's like keying your own car and
slashing your own tires it's going to be
an interesting post game show hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else